VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING.
FOR TUESDAY JUNE ELEVENTH THE
CHAIR NOTICES THE PRESENCE OF OF
FELLOW REPUBLICAN MEMBER BUT
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
TO BE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
FOR THE TIME BEING.
SO WITH THAT SAID WE WILL BEGIN
IN FIVE ORDER WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB THIRTY
BOOKS THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER.
AND AS SENATOR WIENER FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION UP TO THREE MINUTES
IN TOTALITY AGAIN UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR TEST MONEY FOR A
SUPPORTERS.
IN ADDITION TO YOURSELF SO
PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU DEAR AND STUFF -- FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL --
AS WE HAVE A RETURN TRIP --
AFTER THE UNFORTUNATE VETO -- BY --
GOVERNOR BROWN BUT WE'RE
DETERMINED TO GET IT DONE THIS
YEAR -- BECAUSE THIS IS THE THE
DENNIS PERON A BROWNIE MARY --
ACT -- TO ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE -- TO ACCESS
MEDICAL CANNABIS -- VIA DONATION --
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW DENNIS
PERON A BROWNIE MARY WERE TWO OF
THE CALENDARS I DECADES AGO OF
THE MEDICAL CANNABIS -- MOVEMENT
DURING A TIME IN SAN FRANCISCO --
WHEN -- MANY MANY PEOPLE WERE
GETTING VERY VERY SICK AND DYING.
OF HIV -- AIDS AND MEDICAL
CANNABIS HELP THEM TO LIVE
LONGER AND TO BE MORE
COMFORTABLE -- IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE AND DENNIS PERON
A BROWNIE MARY -- WERE KEY -- TO
GIVING PEOPLE -- ACCESS IS NO
CANNABIS AND ALSO TO LEGALIZING
MEDICAL CANNABIS WHICH SERVE
VOTERS DID IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES -- AND THERE'S DONATED
MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR LOW INCOME
PATIENTS HAS BEEN A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PART -- OF CALIFORNIA
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE PEOPLE
WHETHER LIVING WITH HIV OR WITH
CANCER.
ARE VETERANS WITH PTSD -- DON'T
HAVE -- TO USE THEIR FOOD MONEY --
TO PURCHASE OUR MEDICINE AND CAN
GET THAT ACCESS.
AND THESE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS ON OUR CLOSING UP NOW
BECAUSE WHEN THE VOTERS --
LEGALIZED SO DON'T USE OF
CANNABIS -- DAY WE BELIEVE IN
INVER AND LAID OUT -- BALLOT
MEASURE IMPOSED FULL TAXES ON
THESE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE NO REVENUE --
SO OF COURSE THEY CAN'T PAY
TAXES OF THEIR THEIR FOR CLOSING
DOWN.
AND LOW INCOME -- PATIENTS OR
LOSING ACCESS TO THEIR MEDICAL
CANNABIS -- SO THIS BILL -- WILL
SIMPLY -- ELIMINATE TAXES ON
THESE -- DONATED -- DONATION
PROGRAMS -- AND THE PRESIDENT
HER PROGRAMS WILL HAVE TO
PARTNER WITH A LICENSED --
CANNABIS BUSINESS SO THE
REVOLVER GUARDRAILS AROUND IT --
AND WE'RE STRICTLY US FOR AYE
VOTE I DO WANNA NOTES -- THAT
THE POLICE CHIEFS -- AND I THEIR
LOBBYISTS ARE AUTHORIZED THIS IS
THE POLICE CHIEFS HAVE OR
WITHDRAWING THEIR OPPOSITION --
TO THE BILL -- AND SO -- THAT
LETTER IT HAS NOT COME IN YET
BUT WE'RE TOLD TO MAKE COME IN
TODAY -- BUT THEY DID AUTHORIZED
ME TO REPORT THAT TO YOU -- WITH
ME HERE IT'S TESTIFIED -- IS AMY
JENKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SHAUN CURE IN AN WITH WEED
FOR WARRIORS A VETERAN BASED --
COMPASSION PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE CAN UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL.
I'LL MAKE IT QUICK -- REAL QUICK
SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DISABLED
VETERANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKE THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE VA.
IF THERE ARE ABLE THEY CAN MAKE
IT A THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM SSI
SO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
MEDICATE JUST ON A VERY BARNEY
LEVEL WILL SAYS MY MARINE
FRIENDS WILL SAY.
YOU NEED AN EIGHT THE FLOWER DAY
THAT'S BASICALLY FOR JOINTS A
LOT OF PEOPLE'S USE HEALTHIER
MEANS OF ABSORPTION BUT WE'LL
JUST KEEP IT SIMPLE.
AVERAGE EIGHT THIS FORTY DOLLARS
AFTER WE APPLY THAT VERY LOW TAX
RATE IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN ROUND
DOWN. TO FIFTY FIFTY TIMES
THIRTY IS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH SO THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IF THEY BY IN THE
DISPENSARY WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST A VETERAN. TO MEDICATE
PROPERLY AS AN ALTERNATIVE. TWO
BIG PHARMA.
SO WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT IT'S
JUST NOT PRAGMATIC FOR DISABLED
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA TO
MEDICATE AND SO THAT'S WHERE.
SB THIRTY FOUR THESE COMPASSION
PROGRAMS COME IN ALL THESE
VETERANS BACK HERE THEY DO USE
DISPENSARIES BUT THEY CAN'T
MEDICARE FOR THE WHOLE MONTH SO
THAT'S WHERE PROGRAMS LIKE
OURSELVES.
IN OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE OPERATION
NEED BACK IN OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST IN THE STATE -- TO GET
TOGETHER WITH YOU FOR WE USED TO
GIVE FREE METS TO OUR VETERANS%
TO COMPENSATE FOR THAT THAT
ENABLE THEM TO GET OFF THE FORMA
WHICH INCLUDES OVERDOSE
ADDICTION AND SUICIDAL
INCLINATIONS AT FTA STATED.
RISK CANNABIS DOESN'T HAVE THAT
RISK AND NOW WE'RE SEEING
CORRELATION STUDIES IN STATES
WHERE IT'S BEEN LEGALIZED WE
CHAU OVERDOSE IS DOWN IN
SUICIDES ARE DOWN.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS GIVEN OUR VETERANS
A PATHWAY. TO SOMETHING OTHER
THAN THE PHARMACEUTICAL DEBT
THAT WERE SEEN AT EPIDEMIC
LEVELS AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR ME SAID SB THIRTY FOUR IS
NOT GOING TO CURE ALL IT'S ONLY
AN ON RAMP. TO THE LEGAL
COMMUNITY AND RIGHT NOW WE NEED
TO FIX THAT LEGAL COMMUNITY SO
HELP US GET THAT ON RAMP AND
THEN LET US HELP EVERYONE.
GET THE SYSTEM TO WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE TO SERVE THE VETERAN COP
WITH POPULATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION -- ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
HERE -- OBVIOUSLY THIS REMOVE
SOME BARRIERS TO FOR PATIENTS
AND THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS
QUALITY SAFE TESTED MEDICINE --
AND THEN ALSO -- DETERS THESE
PATIENTS FROM GOING TO THE
ILLICIT MARKET WHICH IS A CORE
PRIORITY FOR THIS ASSOCIATION --
AS WELL AS OTHERS IN THAT THE
KIND OF A SPACE SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION SIMPLY AT THE
MICROPHONE.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL CANNABIS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BLAKE JOHNSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF TEACHERS IF YOU WANNA
HEAR SOME SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PAMELA LOPEZ ON
BEHALF OF FLOW KANA AND
OPERATION EVEN A COALITION OF
VETERANS IN SUPPORT.
EVAN QUARTER ON BEHALF A
CONTINUUM IN SUPPORT.
RUSSIA JOHNSON WITH EASE STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANNALYNNE MATHIS WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SABRINA FREDERICK WITH BERKELEY
PATIENTS GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEAL SCHAEFER ON BEHALF OF WHEAT%
FOR WARRIORS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU.
A HUMBLE SO LEASE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JASON BRIAN HUMBLE
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE ONE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHILE I'M SURE WE'D FOR PROJECT
WERE STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S BILL CRANE A MEMBER OF
THE WEED FOR IS PROJECT AND I
HAVE A STRONG SUPPORTER.
MY NAME IS NEIL YARBOROUGH MY
COR COMBAT THAT AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
WITHOUT THIS BILL.
THERE'S GOING TO BE LESS PEOPLE
AROUND OUR OUR GROUPS HAVE GONE
FROM.
A HUNDRED PLUS PEOPLE.
DOWN TO JUST A FEW NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE NEW LOS SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE DONE ABOUT THIS.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUIS MARTINEZ
ON THE LEADERSHIP OF STOCKTON
STRUCTURE WE WE TO ORDERS.
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER THIS.
JUST -- HER MOM BROTHERS AND
SISTERS STAY ALIVE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH ORTIZ
CHAPTER PRESIDENT FOR WE FOR
YOUR PROJECT IN SAN JOSE I MEAN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY FOUR AND THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER AND AS A MILITARY
SEXUAL TRAUMA SURVIVOR I
COMPASSION IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME AND MY VETERAN PATIENTS THANK
YOU.
ROBIN BEVERAGE.
ARMY VETERAN MST SURVIVOR.
I ONLY GET 10% AND DISABILITY.
THAT DOESN'T COVER MEDICATIONS
WITHOUT THIS.
I'M AT RISK FOR SUICIDE SO.
I NEED THIS.
IN GIVING.
GOOD MORNING EDWARD BRESLIN THE
STATE LICENSE MANUFACTURER.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF WEED FOR
YEARS IN OPERATION EVAC PLEASE
ALLOW ME AS A MANUFACTURER TO
CONTINUE.
MY GOAL TO HELP THESE VETERANS
ON THEIR PATH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE QUIT AS
WITH CAN TANA WATSON HURT MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I AM CRISPER CITY MEMBER OF
REFER WARRIORS AND A NO VOTE FOR
THE FOR PROTECTION THANK YOU.
I'M DAVE CASH I'M A DESERT STORM
VETERAN I'VE BEEN SUFFERING FROM
PTSD FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS.
I STOPPED TAKING CIRCLE AND I
STOPPED DOING THAT AND YOU WANT
TO SEE A PICTURE MY ID I WAS
DEAD. ONE FOR HIS BROTHERS RIGHT
HERE I WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
JUDGE ONE TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
I GOT A SOURCE MY VERY.
I'M NOT ON DRUGS NO MORE NO NO
HOME OR NOT.
HE'S GOT SOME OF YOUR TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR.
NAME IS.
MY IS MUCH MEDINA I'M IN SUPPORT
AND WOOD FLOORS.
HI MY NAME IS COLIN WELLS IN THE
FOUNDER OF VETERANS WALKING TALK --
CANNABIS SAVE MY LIFE AND I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR WE'D
FOR LAWYERS IN OPERATION EVAC.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SELENA
MARTINEZ -- I AM A TENTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN. TO SEVEN
OF THE FIRST ELEVEN FAMILIES
HERE.
I'M A 100% DISABLED VETERAN I'M
ONE OF THE YOUNGEST OF THE
VIETNAM VETERANS.
WHEN I CAME HOME I WAS CALLED
THE BABY KILLER BUT WHAT I DID
IS I RESCUE BABIES IN VIETNAM?
CAM A SINGLE PARENT -- AND YOU
KNOW FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS DOES
NOT GET ME VERY FAR AS SAN
FRANCISCO RAISING A TEENAGE
DAUGHTER BY MYSELF --
COMPASSIONATE CANNABIS IS WHAT
SEEKS LICENSEES MY LIFE IN THE
SAVE THE LIVES OF MANY OTHERS
SELECT STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THERE ARE THOMAS HOLDEN STOCKTON
LEADERSHIP FOR WE FOR YEARS AND
NOW WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL JUST AN OPTION AGAINST
OPIOIDS THANK YOU.
MATTHEW WHEATLEY WAS STOCKTON
LEADERSHIP ALSO FOR WEED FOR
WORST STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ROB -- SEAN WOULD READ FOR
WARRIORS STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FOUR THANKS.
SANDER BACON REPRESENT ACCESS OF
LOVE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICTS SIX
WEED FOR WAR YEARS FEMALES
[inaudible]
AND AXES.
OPERATION EVEN AT STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE ANY RETIRED UNITED
STATES MARINE TURNED SOCIAL
WORKER ON SIXTEEN MISSION AT THE
BY N<c.cyan> HOUSE AND I WAS A</c>
FRIEND OF DENNIS'S HE PASSED
LAST YEAR AND HE WOULD BE
APPALLED AT WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW THAT WE KIND OF GOT --
DISENFRANCHISED OF THE
DISENFRANCHISED. TO FIFTEENS WHY
WE HAD IT FOR MEDICINE AND NOW
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT -- YEAH WE
NEED TO CHANGE THAT PLEASE AND I
KNOW GOVERNOR NEW SYMBOL SIGN IT
HE KNOWS IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
PLEASE HELP US WE NEED IT
DESPERATELY TWENTY TWO A DAY.
COMMITTING SUICIDE COSTS UNITED
STATES SO SUB TO US TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND THIS IS
ONE LITTLE THING WE CAN DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOU'RE INTO A
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARC CARRILLO WE'D
FOR PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU.
SEVEN ERICA PELL FOUNDER
VETERANS CANDACE COALITION WE
STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL THE
EFFORTS OF BETTER ADVOCATES.
TO REESTABLISH COMPASSION AS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT FOR LEGALIZATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WHICH IS BEACON SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SINGING NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TO THE AUTHOR.
DR.
THANK YOU -- JUST WALKING A LOT
OF MY CONSTITUENTS HERE FROM
STOCKTON.
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK THIS IS A
REAL ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO GET
OUR ARMS AROUND ANYTIME WE
PASSED LEGISLATION OR OR BARBARA
BILLS PASS OR LAWS PASSED.
THERE'S ALWAYS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND IT'S UP TO US
THAN TO GO BACK IN AND FIX THOSE
LOOPHOLES IN THOSE CONSEQUENCES
THAT WE CREATE OUR SOMETIMES --
SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
QUORUM YET BUT WHEN THERE IS.
THE STOCKTON LEGISLATOR WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
THIS GIVES US OWN AS A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
UNDER WIENER FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND THANK THOSE WHO
BROUGHT THE TESTIMONY.
OF FOUR I READ THE BILL AND I
THINK IT'S A NOBLE -- GESTURES I
BELIEVE THERE'S SOMETHING WE CAN
DO AND CAN FIX AND WE KNOW THAT
INDIVIDUAL TESTIFIED -- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU IN A SAFE
SPACE AND IF THIS HELPS WE WANT
TO BE THERE TO HELP YOU -- SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MATTER AND I WILL
FOLLOW THE KIND GENTLE LADY FROM
STOCKTON WITH THE SECOND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME.
C. NOTICE NO QUESTIONS -- CENTER
WIENER DO IS TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
COLLEAGUES AND I DO JUST WANT TO
I KNOW YOU HEARD THIS FROM SOME
OF THE TESTIMONY THAT -- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEING OVER MEDICATED
WITH OPIOIDS ANOTHER
PHARMACEUTICALS WHO -- HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STOP USING THEM BECAUSE
MEDICAL CANNABIS IS ABLE TO
ALLEVIATE -- THERE ARE MEDICAL
PROBLEMS AND SO -- THIS IS A
POOR FOR MANY REASONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAYS
SEND READER THIS DOES ENJOY AND
I RECOMMENDATION ALSO -- FROM US
YEAH ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
AND I CAN COMMEND YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BACK AGAIN OF FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR AND THE
COMMITMENT THAT YOU'VE HAD ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE SO.
AGAIN WE WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM
WE STEPS INFORMED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NEXT UP
THEN WE'LL MOVE AT AND TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER -- THREE WHICH IS SB
THREE THIRTY FOUR BY DR PAN.
WELCOME DOCTOR.
GOOD MORNING.
THE END.
OKAY THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST ACROSS
THE STATE RESULTING IN A BACKLOG
OF LABORATORY WORK.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED SEVERAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AIMED AT ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE.
SB THREE THIRTY FOR THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BILL WHICH
WOULD ENCOURAGE MEDICAL LAB
TECHNICIANS TO SEEK HIGHER
SKILLED WORK OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD ASK THE STATE
THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTABLISH AN M. L. T. TWO CLS.
CAREER PATHWAY THE PATHWAY IT
WOULD CREATE EXPEDITED PROCESS
FOUR EIGHT NLT MEDICAL.
PLACE STICK MISSION MEDICAL LAB
TECHNICIAN TO OBTAIN LICENSURE
AS A CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST BY
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT
ELIMINATE REDUNDANCIES IN THE
TRAINING BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS.
THE CREATION OF THIS PATHWAY
COULD POTENTIALLY CUT A ONE YEAR
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST TRAINING
PROGRAM BY FOUR MONTHS FOR
ELIGIBLE CANDIDATES.
SB THREE THIRTY FOUR CREATE
INCENTIVES AND UPWARD MOBILITY
FOR MEDICAL LAB TECHNICIANS TO
TRANSITION TO CLINICAL LAB
SCIENTIST LICENSURE TO REPLACE
THOSE EGGS.
EXITING THE WORK FORCE IN THE
FILL POSITIONS NEEDED DUE TO AN
INCREASED WORKLOAD SB THREE
THIRTY FOUR SUPPORT BY LABOR
GROUPS AND LABORATORY
PROFESSIONALS AND I'M PLEASED TO
HAVE WITH ME TODAY ANTI EDISON
THE MEDICAL LABORATORY
TECHNICIAN AT DIGNITY SACRAMENTO.
AND JAY DAVIS A MEDICAL
LABORATORY TECHNICIAN BECAUSE
SACRAMENTO THE SPEAKING SO
REPORT OF THE BILL ALSO HAVE MET
MATT BROAD WITH THE ENGINEERS
AND SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA IS
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR TESTIMONY
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HI AM SHEA DAVIS -- I CURRENTLY
WORK FOR KAISER I'VE BEEN AND
MULTI.
FOR A LITTLE OVER THREE YEARS
NOW -- I COME BEFORE YOU GUYS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- BECAUSE
I GREATLY -- I THINK IT'S A
FEASIBLE PATHWAY FOR EMMA TEASE
TO TRANSITION INTO A CLS.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- IT WILL
HELP CUT OUT SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR SOMEONE
LIKE ME WHO IS SELF RELIANT
FINANCIALLY AND DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE SUPPORT.
OUTSIDE OF MYSELF -- AND I THINK
IT WHICH IS -- MOVE AWAY A
LITTLE -- SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS
TO HELP ME CONTINUE TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND I HUMBLY ASK THAT YOU GUYS --
GIVE YOUR AYE VOTE -- FOR THIS
BILL.
HELLO I AM ANGIE AT SEVEN I AM
MADE DIGNITY HEALTH MLT.
I'VE BEEN A MULTI FOR ABOUT
SEVEN YEARS NOW -- AND HAS
ALWAYS BEEN MY DREAM TO MOVE ON
TO SELL US BUT UNFORTUNATELY AND
BECAME A SINGLE MOTHER.
SO IN ORDER TO MOVE ON I WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE A YEAR OFF OF WORK
IN ORDER TO DO A CLINICAL
INTERNSHIP.
IT WOULD BE.
PARTLY REDUNDANT CONSIDERING I
ALREADY DID SIX MONTHS AS IN A
MULTI AND I WOULD BE.
RE DOING SOME OF THE SAME COURSE
WORK THAT I'VE ALREADY DONE.
SO WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL SO THAT.
PEOPLE LIKE ME CAN MOVE FORWARD
IN MY PROFESSION A LITTLE EASIER
WITHOUT DEVALUING.
WHAT IS ALREADY BEEN DONE?
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
OF CALIFORNIAN THE TEAMSTERS WHO
ARE CO SPONSORS THE BILL WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I BET
THANK YOU.
AND TESTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
HI CHRISTY FOR HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CENTER PRODUCT -- COLLABORATORY
SCIENTISTS WORK HAS TO BACK -- I
SUPPORT.
JONATHAN RIGHT ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA LOCAL
TWENTY I HAVE P. T. E. IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAURICE RICHARDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSE WOULD
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
NO MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ANY
QUESTIONS COMES FROM COULD BE
MEMBERS.
AS THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
CONCERT CAN MEMBERS DOCTOR CAN
DO WISH TO CLOSE -- SHEETS WITH
RESPECT YES WHEN I THOUGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
PAN AND APPRECIATE -- YOU
PRESENTING THIS BILL TO INCREASE --
ACCESS AND LOWERING AT THESE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS WE WILL
FIRST THEN PAUSED TO STOPS A
QUORUM AND THEN TAKE A RIGHT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO HERE.
BLOOM.
ARAMBULA CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
DALY EGGMAN FONG GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
CHECK THE RIVER STEPS THE
CORPSMAN THERE'S I'VE BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND. THREE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THREE THREE FOUR MOTIONS YOU
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW.
I KNOW I PRO ARAMBULA BLOOM CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY DALY AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY.
THE AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS A TWELVE VOTES AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PAN.
THEN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS SB THREE THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR JONES.
SENATE JONES THIS HAS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES THE
I'LL PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
CAN SEE OF THE ASSEMBLY I'LL
JUST SAY THAT.
AND ALL PRESENT THAT AS MY
CLOTHES MY MISTER BELOW IS HERE
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
WONDERFUL.
RESEARCHER MICHAEL -- TO
CALIFORNIA LAND SURVEYORS
ASSOCIATION -- CONSUMER BENEFIT
ALLOWS LICENSEES TO REPORT
MISCONDUCT TO THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS AND LAND
SURVEYORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF HIS BLOOD
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NANCY ICE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCE
AFFAIRS AND GEOLOGISTS.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR AND HIS
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WORKING WITH US ON LANGUAGE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING THEN ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME SEEING NONE AT THIS
BEEN AND A MOTION AND A SECOND
COULD BE SAFER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB THREE THIRTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED LOW LOW AYE BRO
ARAMBULA.
NO I BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
COMING I. DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON
HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- HI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
TING AYE.
FONG.
FONG I LIKE THE WAY YOUR
SECRETARY CALLS ROLE TO THAT AND
YOU GUYS GOT ENGINE IN HERE.
THAT THE BILL HAS A FOURTEEN
VOTES SENATOR AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE TREAT THOSE EQUALLY WITH
THIS TYPE OF RESPECT AND I WILL.
YES SIR BUT I CAN'T ANSWER FROM
MY CHAIRMAN YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AS SEEING THAT -- WE HAVE --
JUST TO ADDITIONAL AUTHORS OF
WILL GO BACK THEN -- TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER -- ONE WE DID NOT A
SUBSEQUENT AT THAT TIME SO WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR FILE ITEM
OF ONE WHICH IS SB THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR WIENER.
THE MOTION A SECOND TWENTY SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB THIRTY FOUR MOTIONS YOU
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION LOW WELL I
BROWN.
READY LET'S.
REVIEW I BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
GIVEN MY GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HELLO MY IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN?
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THEN MOVING
BACK AND FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS SB -- SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR GALGIANI THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE.
CENTER GALGIANI THIS HAS AN I
RECOGNITION ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS
A TECHNICAL BILL THAT DOES THREE
THINGS FIRST IT REPLACES THE
OUTDATED TERMS POUND.
AND POUND MASTER IN CURRENT CODE
WITH THE TERMS ANIMAL SHELTER
AND SHELTER MASTER OR SHELTER
DIRECTOR.
SECOND SB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
REMOVES THE CURRENT REFERENCE IN
CODE TO A PUBLICATION BY THE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION OF THE
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURAL
SCIENCES.
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REGARDING HEALTH CARE STANDARDS
AND REPLACES IT WITH THE CURRENT
PUBLICATION BEING USE TITLED A
GUIDE.
MINIMUM STANDARDS OF COURSE CARE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLISHED BY THE CENTER FOR A
QUIEN HEALTH AT THE SCHOOL OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
FINALLY THIS BILL REPLACES
REFERENCES IN CODE TO THE STATE
HUMANE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
CONTROL DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION.
A MERGER OF THE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS IN ADDITION TO
REMOVING THE NEGATIVE
CONNOTATION THE OUTDATED TERMS
KERRY UPDATING CURRENT LAW TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
PRACTICES.
WILL ASSIST LOCAL ANIMAL CONTROL
AGENCIES TO ENFORCE ANIMAL
WELFARE LAW I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES VERSION
IF WE CAN SUPPORT YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN ROBINSON AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WERE FOR SUSPICION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE FOR
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
AB.
MR BLUE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE A
TROUBLEMAKER HERE -- BUT WHY --
SHELTER MASTER OPPOSED TO
SHELTER DIRECTOR.
IS THERE A REASON WHY IF I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL CORRECTLY
THE THE TERM MASTERS GOING.
TO CONTINUE.
TO BE -- IN THE IN THE LANGUAGE
WHY WAS THAT CHáVEZ SHELTON
MATTER MASTER OR DIRECTOR.
OR DIRECTOR [inaudible]
YES.
I'M NOT SURE WHY WE WOULDN'T
JUST LEAVE IT AT DIRECTOR BUT
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
BOTH TERMS ARE STILL USED.
OKAY THANKS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH I JUST
I JUST FOR CLARIFICATION AS I
SPOKEN TO COMMITTEE STAFF THAT
THE OUT THIS -- THE OUTDATED
TERMS OF POUND OR POUND MASTER --
LOOKS LIKE TO CONCLUDE THAT THE
ANIMAL SHELTER -- AND SHELTER
MASTER SHELTER DIRECTORS SO
GIVING THE OPTIONS OF SUCH. TO
ANY ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATIONS ON
THE DISTINCTION OF POUND MASTER
TO CHANGE TO THAT OF THAT THE
TERMINOLOGY.
CAN.
CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
CNN SATURDAY GALGIANI JEWISH TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS LOW I KNOW I PRO.
AROUND.
THE ROOM TO AYE BLOOM.
THEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU CHU
AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS SEVENTY VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR GALGIANI.
AND WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL AUTHOR AND THEN -- IN
THE MEANTIME WE'LL JUST GO BACK.
IN FILE ORDER SO WILL BEGIN THEN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS SB THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
WIENER THIS ENJOYS IN AYE
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE.
SB THIRTY FOUR MOTIONS YOU
PASSED COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION BLOOM [inaudible]
JUNE [inaudible] TWO I GLORIA
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I PRETTY
.
WILL MOVE THEN.
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE FIVE
NUMBER.
THREE WHICH IS SB THREE THIRTY
FOUR BY DR PATH.
SB THREE THREE FOUR MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS BRO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I TO TO HI FONG FONG
AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
THE BILL HAS A SIXTEEN VOTES
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
SB THREE THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
JONES.
SB THREE THIRTY NINE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED BLOOM.
BUT LIKE. TO TO AYE GLORIA
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
THE BILL HAS SIXTY VOTES AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ACTUALLY HAVE EVERYONE ALREADY.
OF A PHOTO ID TO AND THEN IN THE
MEANTIME ALL WAIT FOR SKINNER
SENATOR SKINNER -- THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO THANK --
SENATOR ELECT BRIAN DAHLE WE FOR
HIS SERVICE IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
IN THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL.
AND AS YOU HEARD.
SENATOR ELECT FROM AND FUTURE
COLLEAGUE OF CENTER JONES ABOUT
THE FISSION SEES OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE FOR THE
SAME TYPE OF CAMARADERIE THAT WE
HAVE A FOUR DID YOU HEAR.
IN THIS BODY.
I LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU -- THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE BEST
COMMITTEES I THINK TO SIT ON AND
I DO WANT TO SAY THOUGH I HAVE
SEEN SENATOR SLAMMED THE DOOR
LEAVE HERE NOT VERY HAPPY SO I'M
HOPING THAT I DON'T GET TREATED --
IN THAT MANNER WHEN I GET OVER
TO THE OTHER HOUSE BUT IT'S BEEN
A PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU YOU
ALL THIS COMMITTEE AND ENJOYED
IT SO TOMORROW AT NOON IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE.
SENATE CHAMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME [inaudible]
MR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
SAY -- THAT IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR ELECT --
AND WISH HIM WELL OVER THE OTHER
HOUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS HOUSE IS
THE BEST HOUSE -- WE KNOW HE'S
GOING TO SERVE HIS COMMUNITY --
WITH DISTINCTION -- IN GREAT
LEADERSHIP YOU WILL BE SORELY
MISSED BUT WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE
OF BE ON SOMEWHERE ON THE FIRST
FLOOR SOMEWHERE -- BUT AGAIN
WISH YOU WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FRIENDSHIP AND YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AND THEN MOUNT -- FOR OUR FINAL
ITEM THEN.
WITH A SENATOR SKINNER THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SB --
ONE FORTY THREE THIS HAS AN I
RECOGNITION ON BOTH SIDES ALLEN
WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE CURRENTLY
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE SO
AGAIN I EMPHASIZE THEOUT THESE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS APOLOGIES FOR KEEPING
YOU WAITING THIS WILL BE AS
AMENDED -- AND THE COMMITTEE --
CAM ANALYSIS SHOWS THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- IT'S NEEDED BILL
IN WITHOUT A LAST FOR YOUR EYES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
HI RYAN FLANAGAN HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE WEST COAST CHAPTER OF THE
INSTITUTE DISCREPANCY I CLING
INDUSTRIES WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WE THINK IT HELPS
MODERNIZE CURRENT LAW TO HELP
CURB METAL THEFT AND FAIRIES
OTHER REASONS.
WE ASK DR THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IT'S
A MESSAGE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
POLIO -- BEHALF OF SCHNITZER
STEEL ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL OR DRIVE A THANK YOU -- HI
AS MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE JUST GIVE OUR FLOW
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH IS
BEGIN SUPPORT SEEN THAN ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SPEND
A MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AS THE ONE HUNDRED THREE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED LOW.
WELL I BROKE ARAMBULA RUBIO AYE
BLOOM WE MY CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
AND I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS EIGHTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATE SKINNER -- THAT COMPLETES
ALL OF THE ITEMS AND THEN WE'LL
JUST MOVE AGAIN INTO FILE ORDER
IF ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISH.
TO VOTE.
SO WILL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB.
THIRTY FOUR SB THIRTY FOUR
MOTIONS YOU PASS A COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION GLORIA.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE
.
THIS SIXTEEN ZERO OF THAT BILL
IS OUT THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB ONE FORTY THREE BY CENTERS
CAN.
SB ONE FORTY THREE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED GLORIA. EIGHTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB THREE THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR PENN.
SB THREE THIRTY FOUR MOTIONS YOU
PASTA APPROPRIATIONS.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
BLOOM GRAYSON AYE BLOOM.
EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
THREE THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR
JOBS.
SB THREE THREE NINE MOTIONS YOU
PASS AS AMENDED GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON. NINE SEVENTEEN ZERO THE
BILL WITHOUT.
THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN SB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
AGENCY ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES
[inaudible]
SPECIAL
.
OKAY ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
OKAY
OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
DURING